when for you as an artist when you are
in the public eye and there's so much
interpretation of things do you go oh
god this is gonna be something that I'm
gonna have to defend or reflect and
people are gonna think it's it's about
something bigger than it actually is
well I think that's I think that was a
huge part of me not consciously not
writing this album about myself you know
and people would say well doesn't it
seem dishonest or doesn't it not seem
like particularly like no one like
people don't necessarily do that you
know even people who don't write their
songs sometimes they you know they pick
songs that reflect how they feel or they
add to them and I am fiercely protective
now of my relationship of my family you
know my ever-growing family and I am NOT
in the interest of sharing anything
about that so the best way for me
because what I do is so creatively he's
tied to it in certain ways and it also
has been in the past you know like the
first album II made it was just
basically a love open love letter to
somebody so I found that it became a
little strangely like a formulaic and
kind of stale to like constantly be
trying to sabotage relationships I was
in just like it write good songs you
know that just seemed like it was God it
got that's actually more dishonest than
what I'm doing now which is drawing upon
a lot of different experiences maybe
experiences with the past that I've had
little kind of hiding them you know in
certain ways and certain songs and not
necessarily you know writing about your
feelings is a very different exercise
than writing about a relationship you
know another thing - I like to speak in
a little bit more general terms because
yeah we talked about this a little
earlier in another interview but there's
this like new and it doesn't come from
everybody there's just new like you
can't hurt me kind of pop song that I
think isn't working because it's
implying that you're stronger than
everyone else and when you look at all
the things are going on in the world and
especially in our country you know
that's invulnerability isn't a real
thing you know and you can you only hide
behind true vulnerability
and I don't know I just felt like that's
not the message to deliver right now
it's like no like people break and
people hurt and they suffer and they or
they cause suffering or they cause hurt
it's much more introspective in that way
of like look I hurt you you hurt me
that's just the way it goes but if we
don't talk about it then we'll never get
through it to me that's not there's
there's not enough of that in a lot of
pop music you know and then and then
there's the pop song that's about like
wow you know you've hurt me and I'm so
fragile and like that's not good either
so there's there's a strut there's a
strength to it but there's I mean it's I
know it sounds crazy these different
things but there's a strength to it and
also a vulnerability to it that I think
is important that it is lost in certain
songs at least one that as far as I'm
concerned I have a very specific way I
want to deliver a message at this point
we all go through this type of stuff so
it's I want people to relate to it and
not feel alienated by it right I want to
talk about you working with the new age
of women that are entering this business
but before I move on you talk about I
mean you are a private person and you
don't like talking about yourself does
that and has that ever brought up the
point of do you still ever think about
leaving this business and moving away
from because it has become it's become a
day and age where everything is so
overtly personalized right everything is
personal everything is wanting to know
about you and what you're posting and
all that stuff has it contantly the way
you like you do this and wanting to do
this no no I well it's changed the way I
do think I mean not really I've always
been that way and it used to be cool you
know it used to be like of course I'm
not a psycho I'm not gonna like share my
entire life with everyone all the time
look I this may make me old-fashioned at
this point but I'll tell you one thing
it certainly makes me balanced and happy
so I don't feel that need to do that and
and part of what makes life real is
existing off-camera and not constantly
just sharing everything with everyone I
think that if you do that you run the
risk of losing yourself and I can tell
you I can give you countless examples of
people who have lost touch with with who
they are they've lost touch with their
own reality like
you know you have to have separation